hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the amnesia custom story lost
the lights I kind of forgot where I was
when I loaded up but I remember I was in
the darkness looking for something
something's watching me which is good
I'm guessing I'm running out of oil very
quickly
I'm running out of oil which may mean
that I will be all alone in the dark
yes I know I heard something man it is
like fate
they can't just like let me run out of
oil but they're gonna or he's gonna I
don't know where it made this ah oil
please that would be lovely
oil oh oh no no no break it open with a
crowbar and I'm about to run out of oil
and that's blocking my path turn that
off oh just drops left scoots in here
come on give me some oil baby oh come on
oops wrong again keep doing that
nope strange weird ball huh no okay all
right then I'm sorry I even tried now I
gotta go in the dark I need to save my
oil for in case I need it but I like
being dark Oh fire of course I might be
going in a big circle I I don't even
know where I've been
it's really hard to tell this is another
map is okay ah so it's like an I am
right here and yeah okay so if I keep
going down this way I can get back to
I'm guessing that's where I came in but
I kind of wanna get back there anyways
because I'm confessed about the
situation can't even see the wall sorry
guys I know it's dark what there's
really nothing I can do about this I
mean I'm gonna run out of oil eventually
so my gonna hold onto it for a special
occasion
I shut up scary you Oh bang on the door
I'm a giant douche ah crowbar perfect
scary big angry guys being murdered
very scary not all right now I can go
back to that door and let me stand in
the light to try to get myself some
sanity back it was a straight down this
way right I didn't take any weird turns
think I did sitting in the life getting
sanity back because I'm the best
strategist and the dark at least I can
see the fog it's something I guess don't
know why you can see fog and pitch
blackness that doesn't make any sense at
all full with this wait a minute have I
been in here I know I have not fifth bet
if what's really funny but sometimes
during the night a man is cleaning our
rooms but we never saw him before
should I tell my mommy and daddy I
probably probably anymore please love
love-love-love some oil me love you long
time
for some oil
moon oil jar this chairs all over the
place
nope no oil Oh
dark dark darker anything in here adult
corner no chair tell me where they
keeping the oil fine okay you tour over
you guys just keep going straight
open oh there's a dead end okay then I
must have turned left here and then I
found the door so dark good thing I'm
not scared of the dark
this would be terrifying ah here we go
this is it right no wait no this isn't
the one it was one I was straight back
here I remember now
cuz that's the door that I went to after
I found the door for the crowbar in here
and there's laughs yeah I say no man
there we go crunch [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
here I mean there aren't even things on
the walls to light I've got these
tinderboxes but nothing to use them on
oil oil beds beds
oil please please oil was it oh this is
just grease there we go why can't I use
it for my lantern mmm
come here I need to borrow you give me
please thank you
ha ha I see like an impulse I can't
control myself
ok I've got the boy I've got the yeah
I've got the oil but not the right oil
for me I've got some oil and there was
some sort of mechanism that I needed to
put oil on whoa pitch blackness Wow
ah no yo juiciest oil huh I can't kill
you why you I don't know maybe because
I'm a giant badass ha ha not today you
shall be fair you shall be big where is
it where is it there is you shall be
failed
yeah stop
what's up monster what's up you ain't
got no no this
I know
no I know I know
I mean he's gonna bother banging in this
door
can't get me I am the gingerbread I feel
little gap up was that I see you
okay what you doing nothing yeah that's
right kid ass - douche douche I'll be
goes away don't run away
okay
hey brother I can't see anything
nothing oh there man I don't know what
you guys can see but I can barely see
the edges of the walls
I won't even know if I like this dump
seems okay it's still here down there up
there is buddy with you okay so if I go
this way I should be fine
I just go this way take it right and
then I'll be on my merry way
yep yeah he's just gonna be wandering
even if he's wandering around the entire
place it's not like he'll what I'm doing
I mean no you're a liar you're a dirty
dirty liar
whoever this guy is he's never good at
this scaring me yeah you didn't hear
okay now now at the top edge of the
place can't see thing okay this
definitely wasn't but I think it was it
was think it was before this my memory
is failing me but I believe I believe I
can fly I believe I can touch the sky I
think about it every night and day
spread my wings and fly away I believe I
can soar right through that open door
but it's just just a dream all right
oh no I went into this is where the guy
would be but I guess he wandered off
okay
I was up there I'm done here must be
somewhere around here
nothing come on I'm gonna walk right
into the guy I wish I could see this is
where I came in I have no idea probably
probably probably oh here's another
matter okay all right this is the back
at the beginning okay so if I go back up
I think it's somewhere around that top
right area is what I saw maybe I don't
even need to anything else in here maybe
I was just supposed to get the oil and
get out I don't know
and take a sanity potion what was that
was that a scream I heard or just a
squeak of a stupid Mouse oh oh
once badly oh this is that room where I
got the crowbar um show me the money
show me some why can't you just have one
candle on the wall no one would have
enough frickin lantern oil for this
what's this over here hello goop up in
here oh no this is the entrance hey
check maybe I can't remember can't
remember where the oil is war
no the oil it was further oh maybe maybe
[Music]
maybe still dark oh why did it get so
dark oh it's okay I think there was
something for the oil downstairs wasn't
there either that I'm gonna waste a bit
of time but I really think so there was
something for the oil and I think it was
down here
I thank you thunk mmm
now who knows either way it's not that
big of a deal it's just a little like
taking a minute out of my way it's not
like I know the answer anyway so might
as well try everything
um um no damn it it was something up
there wasn't it damn it
all right I wasted some time all right
fine
yeah yeah you're all laughing at me big
idiot wasting everybody's time sorry
about that ladies and gentlemen out
there I hope my it's crazy handsome this
can make it up to you yeah yeah all
right it must have been something out
there something about some gears that
needed to be oiled or some lever that
need to be oiled it would help if I
could see anything but I've got nothing
I've got nothing I'm just totally boned
from start to finish I never notice the
blood on the walls that's a nice touch
forbidden hotels for high quality
version and easy custom story lost the
lights all right I don't even think that
guy is patrolling anymore when I first
came in here I took a right and then I
found something with oil war there's
something outside of this hotel I have
no idea
shut up
friggin man the door open over there
that open over there I want to be I wish
I could have had an ability to zoom in
okay that's where I that's where the the
monster chased me but it is open it is
not damn it all right oil
do you need to oil this nope okay all
right that wasn't it so I'm gonna go
back and I'm gonna take a left cuz why
came in here first I took a right and
then I went around
I must have found something for this oil
don't think it was down there cuz I came
down there Oh
cannot see cannot see cannot see I'm
gonna mess it just because I won't be
able to see jack
nope not scary not scary at all woah
here please tell me yes please is this
it I think this is it alright it's
Alexander alright was there something
behind here wait ah
anything yeah this is it this is it
totally it wait what come on this was it
oh it was stuck I was supposed to get
oil for this right right don't tell me
that ah haha there we go yes yes awesome
epic I'm the best and actually I'm a
talk real slow I'm actually out of time
so thank you guys so much for watching I
do appreciate each and every one of you
you're all beautiful the girls and you
guys are very handsome dashing even
dapper and as always I will see you in
the next part
bye bye